i think the best advice we got was
something we probably got a lot was you
know whether we
we won or lost that we actually won
because we were here we made it we made
it here with this film and
we have people talking about this film
and i think that's a big win for
everybody
you know the worst advice we got was uh
are you guys sure you want to try and do
it this year
yes lawrence yes lauren
our next question is going to be from b
b live
hi how are you okay
this is me jake sims bbe live and first
of all i want to say congratulations to
you guys
congratulations thank you so what has
been your reaction thus far
just winning this particular award for
your tremendous work
i you know when we started this journey
to make this film we knew
i especially knew it would be a film
that would be
difficult for people to to watch
difficult for people to
you know politically even engage with
and
for it to have done what it's done and
for us to be here holding these for a
movie
as as potent and as
as serious as our film is
from the academy i i think it's
it's unbelievable i think it's it's it's
amazing to think that we could be
standing here today
holding oscars for a film about police
brutality i think that's incredible
all right thank you for your time
congratulations
thank you thank you our next question is
from young
bold and regal i saw the film and i was
just
astounded by the depth of it when it
came to
making it a short film tell me about the
process
of how you guys went about making it
um you know it started with with an idea
i had an idea
while we were out protesting and
marching that was spurred on by
how i was feeling about what i was
seeing how i was feeling about
internalizing uh you know the pain of
seeing so many black people be killed at
the hands of the police and
and thinking about the emotional
uh you know roller coaster you go on
every time you hear a new name or a new
story or see a new video
it put me in the mindset of you know
this feels like living the worst version
of groundhog day and when i
had that thought to myself it was
something that i
uh you know i couldn't put it away it
would not go away and so
because it was the pandemic and we
weren't working we weren't doing
anything i felt like
you know i wanted to probably sit down
and do something with him so i told
martin about the idea
and and you know i asked him if this was
something that we could make
or and do right like right now and you
know which was crazy at the time it was
a pandemic
and we're trying to make a short film
which you know how do you even go about
doing that in
in a regular uh or a non-pandemic time
period and
to do it then at the time seemed crazy
but you know
we kind of defied that all the way to
this stage here
i i'm i'm biblica i
our next question is from blackfilm.com
ellen
congratulations on this epic win um the
chemistry
cinematic chemistry between the perry of
you is pretty strong
any future plans to work together again
i'm crossing my fingers yes
oh yeah i think i mean he better not be
going anywhere i think
he's gonna go he can't hide he's right
there i know where he's at just follow
the yellow hair i think we got a long
road ahead of
us of making many more movies many many
[Music]
years